OK, there was a complete total softball, pandering
brownnosing interview that Donald Trump did
on Fox News with Sean Hannity on Thursday
night.
Let's look at some clips will jump right into
it.
The sort of framework here was Donald Trump
doing a media tour because of the death of
radical right wing radio host Rush Limbaugh?
Reminder, Rush Limbaugh celebrated the death
of Ruth Bader Ginsburg, celebrated the deaths
of AIDS victims in the 90s.
Not a good guy.
Trump calling in.
And Hannity starts in with, you know, Mr.
President, sir, it was such a great idea to
give Rush Limbaugh the Presidential Medal
of Freedom.
How did you come up with such a great idea?
Total suck up.
Let's take a listen.
A true original.
Joining us now on the phone is President Donald
Trump.
Mr. President, I know that the honor of his
life came from you.
And what that Medal of Freedom meant to him,
I know the behind the scenes story, I know
I know who made the first call to me anyway
was Matt Drudge and and Jared Kushner.
And and I know you made your decision and
with Melania there in about five seconds and
you said that's a great idea.
Tell us about it.
Well, it was an idea that we had that a lot
of people suggested to me, frankly, a lot
of great people of our country, largely Republicans.
It was an amazing night because the Republicans
went wild and the Democrats sat there.
But they all respected Rush.
And I think it was, you know, one of the great
honors of his life, Presidential Medal of
Freedom.
It's a big deal.
And he he was very honored by it.
And he was a great gentleman, just like Mark
said.
I listened to Mark and Mark is so terrific.
But, you know, he said he's special and Rush
was really special.
He was a very special guy.
And you said irreplaceable.
And it's true.
He is irreplaceable.
Again, Trump deciding that the thing he gave
Rush was the thing Rush was the most honored
by.
Trump needs that to be true for his own narcissism.
And he keeps repeating that the right loves
Rush and the left respected Rush.
I don't know anyone on the left that respected
Rush Limbaugh.
I don't know anyone on the left who would
have respect for people who celebrate the
deaths of people with AIDS or celebrate the
death of Ruth Bader Ginsburg.
These aren't mere political differences about
what the tax rate should be, where you say,
hey, you know what, we disagree, but I respect
their point of view.
Cheering AIDS deaths has nothing respectable
about it.
It is a bizarre thing for Donald Trump to
keep repeating.
Then Hannity goes into even more sucking up
to Trump.
And Trump again reveals that the thing he
really likes about Rush is that he supported
Trump.
That's all Trump cares about.
You know, there's this side of you that I
know a lot of Americans don't know and I know
many people that this story holds true for.
And I know in the case of Rush and when Rush
had his diagnosis a little over a year ago,
I knew you were calling him regularly, minimum
of once a month, often much more than that.
And you would always be checking with how
are you feeling?
How are the treatments, how's everything going?
And and I know you talked to him a lot.
What were those conversations like?
Well, it was interesting because I didn't
know Rush at all, as you know, I didn't know
him at all until I had gotten word that from
somebody that Russia was with us all the way.
He was you know, we have this guy who was
so big on radio.
I knew a lot about Russia, but I didn't know
him.
And he was with me all the way.
And it was sort of incredible.
I got to know him after that.
And he was much different, actually.
You know, when you were there was a very,
very I wouldn't say not outgoing, but he was
very, very warm and he was just a very warm
person.
And and, you know, when people got to know
him, I loved playing golf with Russian as
I used to call on the bull because he was
actually a very strong guy, physically very
strong guy.
And he hit the ball a long way when he hit
it big, went a long way.
And but you got to know him.
And he and he loved this country and he loved
his wife.
All the things Trump says about Rush, his
ratings, his ability to do a radio show, all
that stuff, it would all be equally true even
if Russia didn't support Trump.
But you and I know that if Rush was an anti
Trump Republican who died, Donald Trump would
not be doing this.
Donald Trump doesn't have friends.
The only thing that matters to Trump is, are
you a brownnosing sycophant?
If so, I'll call you a friend until you say
the wrong thing.
And then I say you're, you know, what's that
lightweight as he often says, what you do,
what you do for me and what you've done lately
is all that matters to Donald Trump.
Let's look at a little bit more of this.
Here is Sean Hannity with just a stunning
brownnosing of Trump saying, hey, here were
Russia's top issues.
These are your issues as well, sir.
Mr. President Trump on Russia's show today.
And I was listening for I began my radio program
and they played a segment of Rush.
And in that segment, he said if you took tapes
of him when he started in nineteen eighty
eight and syndication again, nobody thought
that that anyone can syndicate during the
daytime and be successful.
And he proved all the naysayers wrong.
And if you look at where he stood, conservative
justices, liberty, freedom, less government
intrusion, intrusion, less regulation, less
taxes, lower taxes, energy independence, secure
borders, choice and schools.
The Second Amendment.
Free and fair trade.
Peace through strength.
Sound familiar?
Because that's your agenda.
That's what you did.
He was right there.
He understood it.
He got it.
And he's been that way for a long time.
You know, he hasn't been somebody that's changed.
He didn't go from being a liberal to being
a conservative.
I mean, he was there from the beginning and
he hasn't changed his views and changed very
much.
And his audiences, you know better than probably
anybody in the loyalty of his audience was
just incredible, staggering.
It's actually interesting and sad how never
changing your views is seen as a badge of
honor in some circles on the right and on
the left.
And as I've said many times, having the exact
same views for fifty years likely means you're
not learning anything.
Now, I want to be really clear.
I don't mean it's typical for, say, a 40 year
old not talking about anyone in particular
for a forty year old to have a complete political
awakening and and 180 degree reversal where
all of a sudden they denounce everything they
stood for for forty years and say, I was wrong
all along and I'm actually a right wing nut.
OK, that raises red flags and it suggests
to me grifting.
But what I'm talking about is saying your
views haven't changed at all for forty, fifty
years, as if it's a badge of honor.
Look at how much we've learned about life
and humanity and the planet in 50 years.
How could your views not change over that
period of time?
Even my views on many issues are modified
and adjusted and updated to account for new
things that we know.
It's sad and it doesn't bode well for the
country to see that praised as a badge of
honor.
Just one more clip here.
Hannity explaining what might have been so
damaging to Kayleigh McEnany.
Listen to this.
Your own Kayleigh McEnany, I mentioned earlier
tweeted that she was a rush baby.
Dad was listening in the car and and it shaped
her viewpoint to conservatism.
And he did that for so many of us and so many
around the country.
I want to thank you.
I appreciate you being on the program.
I know I read your statement the other day,
and I know you said in the in the months ahead,
you have a lot you want to tell us.
And we won't do it tonight, obviously.
But when that when that time comes, we're
looking forward to hearing what your future
plans are and what you are planning to do.
I have a funny feeling we're going to hear
a lot more from Donald Trump.
My instincts are correct.
Well, there's a lot to talk about, and our
country is a great place and we're going to
make it even greater as the expression goes,
but we have a lot to talk about.
But today is all about Rush, don't you think?
And so Hannity mentions there that growing
up as a little kid, Kayleigh McEnany, Trump's
former press secretary, would have Rush Limbaugh
playing in the background because that's what
her dad listen to.
You know, that explains so much.
And that is a cautionary tale, not to have
radical right wing radio playing in the background
when you were trying to raise well-adjusted
kids.
A real lesson in parenting there.
So Trump back on Fox News.
There it is.
We'll see what role Trump plays or doesn't
play in the Republican Party going forward.
And you can let me know your thoughts about
Trump's return to the airwaves.
I'm on Twitter
at David Pakman,